oui comme tu connais bien ces missions
connaît bien merci tu te feras s'assurer
connaissez bien patrick sébastien et re
c'est une erreur d'avoir laissé partir
bah vous avez vu le résultat mais vous
pareil bourdin la radio donnez vous
savez bien où déstabiliser et
téléspectateurs quand vous enlevez vous
qui marchait patrick c'est un vrai
rendez vous je vous avais expliqué quand
j'étais arrivé à france télévisions on
avait regardé d'être des téléspectateurs
qui disait moi j'ai pas les moyens ou
les théâtres sont trop loin de là où je
me trouve donc je m'habille avec mon
mari je veux mes droits télés jemâa
smoking et j'ai le spectacle chez moi à
il faut pas oublier que la france elle
est grande il la connaît bien la france
donc ce que je dis le sait puisque j'en
ai parlé on a parlé ensemble 25 fois
patrick cosnet connais plus que n'a pas
jeudi la patrie qu'est ce que je peux
commencer en question la france elle a
évolué je connaissais non mais je n'ai
rien contre mais parce que moi j'ai une
france télévisions je leur ai dit plein
de fois et ils m'ont dit un truc tu me
dis si c'est vrai ils m'ont dit que tu
avais vu le d'ailleurs ces nanas qui
avait vu la patronne de france team à
moi je suis la patronne j'ai vu dix
minutes en cinq ans voilà il paraît
qu'elle lui avait dit patrick sébastien
on va lui donner des beaucoup de prime
sur france 3 on veut le mettre sur
france 3 ça va être la figure de proue
de france pendant la jeune mannequin ça
jamais ahmed aurait dû s'arrêter
moi je moi j'avais envie de faire ils
disent que voilà non non ils disent que
l'intrus qui sont pas vrai on a pas on
n'y a personne en face qui m'a dit on va
te donner des points sur france 3 n'ont
jamais la com comme on a dit il faut
moderniser les missions compagnie faut
moderniser les missions qu'ils soient
sont je voulais pas en faire ce qui
s'est passé expects acculèrent
moderniser l'émission c'était mettre la
mettre les artistes au service de la
réalisation lieu du compte ça t'énerve
est spectaculaire ou pas ça m'a énervé
c'est par rapport aux artistes on s'est
toujours battu pour mettre les artistes
en valeur et la réalisation dont qui
était sommaire ne soient au service des
artistes et là on a mis tellement de
lumière de machin de trickett s'est de
l'irak les gens étaient perdus et puis
les enthousiasmes sur promoteur c'est
pas mon truc je me faire dire des
conneries et de sincère spectaculaire
salut
forcément vous mettre un peu les boules
parce que ça non on est bon sans être
c'était pas bien fait c'était moins bien
que le grand cabaret on est 200 fois
c'est venu chez moi là et on peut pas
bien vivre de se faire renverser par une
gêne qui reprend ce ce format qui est
honnêtement le cost low cost c'est pas
possible eh oui c'est pas le cos c'est
qu'ils sont imaginé que c'était facile à
faire c'est comme tout us et cyril c'est
comme quelqu'un qui va venir ici qui va
les ondes c'est facile moi je me mets
derrière le truc et puis je prends des
chroniqueurs et puis on va faire pareil
c'est pas si simple que ça un vrai
producteur il le sait nicolas il sait à
quel point je me suis investi dans la
fabrication dans les numéros dans
l'ordre des numéros je vais ruiner tous
les lumières il faut savoir quand j'ai
appris qu'elle line chimie je regarde
encore les prime de france 2 le samedi
soir ou jamais non je regarde de temps
en temps des trucs qui me plaisent bien
j'ai eu un documentaire fabuleux sur les
que sur les paysans j'ai trouvé ça s des
forces apparaît d'ailleurs là il ya des
trous mais c'est vrai que franchement je
regarde pas parce que parce que ces
élites east parce que le grand échiquier
surtout que on va te remplacer par du
nouveau serait le grand échiquier sur le
grand des élections qui existait avant
il ya des bonnes choses mais franchement
ça ne m'intéresse pas quoi cette voiture
je dis un truc je te le dis tu ne nous
paie rapt ou bien parce que je te dis
quand tu sera programmée en face du
grand échiquier sur france 2 / civile tu
seras devant saphir sur 10radio grande
audience et je te le signe aujourd'hui
de cyril ce qu'il faut que tu saches moi
j'ai soixante cette pige j'ai fait
trente ans de télé je me suis régalé
jusqu'aux dernières années je me suis
amusée je suis très conscient on a dit
les hommes blonde plus de 50 ans mais
j'allais 67
il va me rester que ce que je suis en
effet quoi 10 pistes à tout casser
je fais pas les m'emmerder je vais je
vais vivre sur sur les souvenirs je
crois tous les jours des gens qui ont
grandi avec des émissions vous fondez
cela je vais pas les prendre le risque
alors justement télé peut faire démonter
j'ai autre chose à autre chose à vivre